we must now select my successor and to
tell me well man the opposition will
accept he stands for one thing and one
thing only himself why have I been
forced to send potential his black holes
into catastrophe let the true qualities
do you lack of vanity my lion will your
sense of humor oh ho ho
your majesty it is my duty to invite you
to take up the position of Prime
Minister of this United Kingdom I speak
to you for the first job as Frank
minister the Germans have encircled
sixteen British and French divisions we
are looking at the clouds' Western
Europe for the next few days telling you
they got a free don't rescue them maybe
two days we would need a miracle to get
on them hubs it's more way to go out on
your shoulders
we are facing certain defeat on land the
annihilation of our army and imminent
invasion we must negotiate peace talks
when would allegedly learn you cannot
reason with a tiger when your head is in
its mouth nonsense the only slippery
slope would you stop interrupting me
while I am interrupting you we have
before us many many long months of
struggle and saplings
even though many old and famous states
are fallen into the grip of the nerves
in rule we shall defend our island
whatever the cost may be
we shall fight on the beaches we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
fight in the fields and in the streets
we shall fight in the Hills we shall
never panic
while we run hit me yes can you know
survival
you